We predicted that the Southern District of
New York prosecution, a district attorney,
would be a thorn in the side of Donald Trump
and his family long after he was out of office.
That may still be the case, but it is Georgia that
is jumping ahead very quickly and has launched
a criminal investigation into Donald Trump's
supposedly perfect phone call to Georgia officials
saying that they need to find eleven thousand
seven hundred and eighty votes for him. Yes,
Donald Trump is under criminal
investigation. It's happening
even more quickly than some of us anticipated it
might happen. The New York Times reporting that
prosecutors in Georgia have started a criminal
probe into Donald Trump's attempts to overturn
the election results in Georgia, including
that infamous phone call he made to Republican
Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger. That's
the call where Trump insisted I only need eleven
thousand seven hundred and eighty votes.
What are we going to do? Help me out here.
How can we find these votes? Fannie Willis, who
is the Democratic prosecutor in Fulton County,
has now sent a letter to numerous officials in
state government, including Brad Raffensperger,
requesting that documents be preserved related
to an investigation into attempts to influence
the state's 2020 presidential election. So
this is notable for a few different reasons.
These notifications to preserve documents are
typical when there is an investigation that is
taking place, because this is a prosecutor in
Fulton County. We know that this is a criminal
investigation. That's what it is. That's what it
means. That's what these prosecutors investigate.
Now, the letter does not mention Donald Trump by
name, but it is related to what Donald Trump did,
trying to change the outcome of Georgia's
election, insisting that these officials
should simply find these votes, make it happen.
And a copy of this letter that was sent was
obtained by The New York Times. And it really
doesn't look good for Donald Trump. Now, the
speculation is Trump's ultimately going to be
charged with felony election fraud and that one
of the really important things to understand
is that when it comes to these statutes,
even if you fail to convince someone to do the
thing you want them to do, it is still a crime.
Quote, Under Georgia law, it is illegal to falsify
any records used in connection with an election
or to place false entries in such records.
And any person who solicits requests,
commands, import tunes or otherwise attempts to
cause the other person to falsify election fraud
in the first degree to falsify voting records
is guilty of criminal solicitation to commit
election fraud in the first degree. This is a
felony offense. And much like with bribery, if.
You try to bribe someone and they don't accept
the bribe, you're still guilty if you I mean,
listen, when we talk about attempted murder, just
because you failed to kill someone doesn't mean
you've committed no crime and much the same way,
even if you fail to induce fraud by asking someone
in this case, Brad Raffensperger, to find these
eleven thousand seven hundred and eighty votes,
you are still culpable even if you don't get
them to do the thing you're asking them to do.
Imagine if Georgia ruins Donald
Trump's life before New York. Does
everyone expecting Southern District of New
York to be the never ending thorn in Trump's
side in Georgia? Jumping ahead very quickly
now from the standpoint of Trump's defense.
The president, the former president is known for
not paying bills of all kinds in real estate,
not paying contractors that he hires to do windows
or whatever it is he needs at different buildings
as president known for not paying legal fees.
Who's going to defend Donald Trump? And is it
still worth it to them to do it simply to say
you're defending the president even if you're
not going to get paid? Is it worth it for the
notoriety? Is it worth it for the publicity and
the PR? I don't know the answer, but it seems
as though Donald Trump is going to need a lot
a lot of different lawyers over the next several
years. This is just the start. And, you know, I
think from the standpoint of setting expectations.
We know what the defense will be about, find 780
eleven thousand seven hundred and eighty votes and
we talked about this on the bonus show yesterday.
It is going to be Donald Trump wasn't asking
someone to commit fraud. Donald Trump really
believed this is what they'll say. We don't
know if it's the truth. Donald Trump really
believed he won in the state of Georgia. And
what he was pointing out was it was only eleven
thousand seven hundred and eighty votes of
margin. And that what Trump was saying was,
we don't need to fix every fraudulent vote. We
just need to fix eleven thousand seven hundred
and eighty. It will go to Donald Trump's mindset
at the time. It will go to Donald Trump's beliefs
at the time. I have no delusion that this would
be an easy case to prove. And I've had a number
of lawyers email me about this reality. Similar
similar to with perjury. Just because you said
something untrue under oath doesn't mean it's
necessarily perjury. You have to prove intent.
And that's why it's very difficult to prove
perjury. That's why you don't often see it
prosecuted when incorrect statements are made
under oath during trials and the same complexity
will come up here. That doesn't mean Trump
won't need lawyers to defend him. He will.
And the question of who is it going to be? I
can't imagine it's going to be Bruce Castor.
I don't think David Shoun would be interested in
this one, nor nor do I think it's his specialty.
So the next months and years are going
to be very interesting. But for today,
yes, a criminal investigation apparently launched
by Georgia into Donald Trump's supposedly perfect
phone call. That's his designation. Nobody else is
calling it that. And we will see where that goes.
Tell me what you expect in terms of these
investigations. Criminal, civil and otherwise.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.